let's go back to the phones let's go to
chelsea in kansas city missouri
chelsea what's up hi john
how are you i am outstanding how about
you
i'm doing awesome good so how can i help
this morning
i have recently gone through a divorce
and i'm getting back out into the dating
scene
and i just it's hard i'm in my mid-30s
and i just want some guidance on how to
make this work and i have two kids
two young kids six and two so six and
two so how long were you married
um that's interesting i was married for
a year then we divorced for a year
and i had my daughter with two at the
time and
i dated somebody and it just scared me
so much i remarried my ex-husband again
and we had another kid and then so you
were
you remarried because you got scared you
remarried because you got scared are you
remarried you dated somebody new
and thought no he's the one i love him
or i don't want to invest in any more
time than anybody else
what was the reason you went back it
wasn't cause you were scared why did you
really go back and remarry him
well it it was kind of out of fear
because i didn't want my daughter
to grow up in a in a split home
with like having to choose like
a new parent and a new family so
so you weren't scared of a new
relationship you were scared of your
daughter
growing up in a in a separate house okay
that makes sense yeah
and so why'd you get divorced a second
time to the same guy
for the same reasons we just aren't
compatible we just don't get along we
don't have the same life goals
give me some more details than just not
compatible and there's a reason why i'm
asking this
um but not just to be gratuitous yeah
well
he doesn't have the same work ethic as
me drive
we don't agree on parenting his parents
pretty much hand him everything and
don't really make him work hard for
anything and
my mom is completely the opposite of
that we've always had to work really
hard for everything in our life
so those things sound like those things
sound like some things that every couple
goes through
something below that made you get
divorced twice
what is it those are just discomforts
those are things that every couple deals
with i thought we should do this i
should do this
those are usually navigational issues
something below that made you get
divorced twice
we got married because i got pregnant
okay my daughter
so i married him because i thought it
was the right thing to do for her
ah there we go and did you did you
resent him
um no
i i didn't at the time i think i did
more now i just kind of felt like i was
doing the right thing like
god picked him for me because i was so
bad at picking people before and then
that happened and i was like well
this is the one hmm and thought that i
could learn to love him and i
i guess that's kind of where i'm like
getting into the dating scene i don't
want to just learn to love somebody but
i also
know the butterflies and the fireworks
that's not always healthy either
right right right so here's a couple of
things i could pass on to you
um learn to i'm making a note here
so i think first i want to differentiate
between learn
to and choose to
learn to suggest that something is going
to come from out there
and present itself to you as like new
knowledge or new information
or new things you can brush under the
rug like he's just gross and or he's
rude or he
yells at our kids instead of hugs
whatever the things are and you're gonna
learn to deal with those things
and that's not a healthy way to approach
relationships you can learn new
information
to process it and you use the
information but just
learning to that's not a good way to
look at it i do believe with
all of my heart this idea of choosing
you do choose to be in love um you do
choose to be in a relationship you do
choose to remain
married there's a great theologian rich
mullins who once said the worst part
about being a christian is that it's
every single day
and you can never memorize enough
scripture that you don't got to get up
and try to live right the next day
that same thing applies to exercise
right you can never have such a good
workout on a monday that you're squared
up for the rest of the month the worst
part about being in shape is you've got
to get up on tuesday and work out again
and get up on on wednesday and either
rest or
fix your body and work out again love is
the same way
and i heard this maybe a few months ago
and it stuck in my soul
where do you think we get our most
um detailed metaphor for love the the
picture we get
of romance and of love and of starstruck
love and i just gave you a hint there
where does that come from where's our
picture of
ultimate love come from
i have no idea all right here's where it
comes from romeo and juliet
okay romeo and juliet two star struck
lovers who see each other from across
the room at a party
the gods faded them together and then
they end up dying because their love is
so is so
deep or maybe titanic right
or the notebook or any of these things
where you see somebody it's
it and then you are willing to die and
the reality is this
like romeo and juliet were two teenagers
who wanted to hook up
they secretly got married and they threw
a temper tantrum and one killed the
other one and then killed himself
and so these two 16 year olds have
become our model
right or jack and rose on a boat
um and i forgot rachel mcadams and
gosling i forgot their
their character names um kelly through
the booth has given me a hard time here
noah and ally she couldn't let it be
noah and ally right
here's the thing love in relationship
in marriage is a choice and so what you
are gonna have to do when you head back
out there chelsea is you're gonna have
to decide
i want to love this person and if you
get the butterflies and the feelings and
the things that's great
or you're gonna choose not to love that
person right so that's number one
number two you're gonna find out about
yourself
and childhood insecurities all of these
do i look good am i first in line does
he
like me does he listen to me do i have
acne
all these things that you thought you
did away with in middle school will come
flooding back to you and so most people
get caught off guard
honestly most many people get caught off
guard by this re-emergence of this
little girl or these little boy
insecurities that come
rushing out after having been in a
long-term relationship and you'll get
this sense like man i thought i would be
past this by now i thought i'd be all
growed up and everything be all good
the reality is no those things live deep
in you because they're only healed
through relationship
and now you're dealing with a fractured
relationship and the final thing i'll
tell you is this
expect to have doubts about your
judgment or
another way i could say it is you're
gonna lose trust in yourself
because you thought that god told you to
do something when you got pregnant and
so you got married
and then you chose to get divorced
and you thought that was the right thing
and then you got remarried
and then you got divorced again so most
people forget
when they get divorced they're not just
losing a partner they're not losing a
dream they're not losing
a future they're also
dealing with lost trust in themselves
and so what i want to recommend is you
go out
as you start hitting the dating scene
obviously you're going to respect your
kids right you're not going to bring
home knuckleheads to meet your kids
until you are very very serious you're
not going to drag them through a series
of relationships so that goes without
saying
but i want you to have somebody that you
can talk to whether it's a close friend
and not just like a yeah girl
not a friend like that but somebody
who's a little bit older a little bit
wiser maybe somebody's been
remarried maybe a counselor maybe
somebody at your local church somebody
who
will walk with you and will give you
some insight and some wisdom
to deal with the exciting butterfly
moments the the middle school high
school moments
and then the middle school high school
college and securities
and the ups and the downs and then as
you choose
not as you feel fated or as you feel
oh it's going to happen but as you
choose to say
this is the guy that i want to spend the
rest of my life with this
is the guy that i'm going to get up
every day
and decide that i'm going to love
this is the guy that i'm going to lean
in towards
even when he's annoying even when he's
frustrating even when i feel vulnerable
that's going to be the guy that you end
up with that's going to be the guy
that's going to help you have a healthy
marriage
and i'm going to expect him to do the
same thing for you i'm going to expect
him to choose you
every day and choosing is so
so hard so prepare to feel insecure
again prepare to feel like you don't
trust your instincts anymore
prepare to have somebody that walks with
you a community of people
that you trust go for it man go for it
chelsea
protect your kids in this process and
protect your heart so thank you so much
for the call